we do know the first episode is the one
and only renee zellweger and you said
well we get to know these celebrities
intimately
do you want to answer this uh no i think
i think this is for you buddy it's all
for you
no you know what it is with renee and
that was the moment you guys met
was it instant
i think you should answer that
christy was it instant i mean you know
there was sparks flying on set i mean
lots of sparks and i'm specifically
talking about grinding because we did
grind
and weld
on the ford bronco i was busy removing
the seats and working under the hood on
the 442 so renee and i were very busy
working
and
she's doing that you know the journalist
eyes and the lean in the leaning
i mean i guess there's no way for me to
avoid it no
and
um you know the irony is is that
iou thank you discovery plus because um
yeah
i wish they could take me off their date
about the database now because
the dating service is over listen there
is nothing better than selling finding
love and celebrating love to me i really
think so and i think i'm looking awkward
now no you're smiling really big and
it's actually very very endearing
yes it's super endearing but you know
what i think it was if i if i may but i
don't know y'all at all but i'm gonna
i'm gonna put my two cents in
she really knows cars renee really knows
cars and that had to have been
attractive uh
i mean wait
let's talk about the moment where we
both pull in two different vehicles and
we pull in the ford bronco we pull in
the 442. yeah she sees that convertible
442 yeah and just like hops right in
like right over the door hops in the
driver's seat fires it up and we're kind
of okay okay what's going on and then
pops it in gear and takes off mind you
we're inside a building and i think that
was the moment where we're like wait a
minute you know if you didn't know your
way around a car you wouldn't just
happen to do that so her and i had
already kind of had the car girl chat
okay and i mean there was the proofs in
the pudding or the proofs in second gear
maybe yeah and what's really nice about
the show is that that shows how
authentic it was the door was unable to
open yeah she did jump in she did drive
and in the episode you know the editor
left it raw you see crew diving out of
the way and you catch the cameraman it
was a moment of break in the fourth rule
because you know it was real we are car
people yeah and there is no greater gift
than to give somebody who's also a car
person
this is an opportunity
to see a little bit behind the curve
yeah and i know you know renee in
particular she doesn't give herself
freely outside of maybe she's very
private so she's a very private person
and that's something i really love about
her and she um you know she really gave
herself you got to see a side of her
that was really real and she
really shared that yes renee is very
private but she's also one of the nicest
people that i've ever met in hollywood
no joke hands down oh yeah
oh yes honey we've met
i mean
you're doing fine on your own bud in the
episode you said um you when and i i
hope it was just a joke when you were
like you know the bridgette jones part
where you said she would you know use
the accent the whole time you're like
wait wait what that was an accident yes
of course
you didn't you knew that that was
well at that point
i would like to
at that point they hadn't met yet oh
what you hadn't stopped talking remember
this story i told about the bus that i
liked so much that i like driving it too
i just have to ask what do you what do
you like most about renee
okay so next question
thank you love the chicken world
stay on cars
you